one reason that people are so scared is
that the numbers just keep going up
according to Johns Hopkins more than 1.3
million Americans are now confirmed to
have gotten sick from this virus the
death toll is now surpassed 82,000 John
Hopkins dr. Tom Ingoldsby will testify
about the pandemic before a House
Committee a little later today he is a
director of the center for the health
security at the university's Bloomberg
School of Public Health and he joins us
this morning good to see you dr.
Inglesby let's get right to the numbers
because we keep hearing Los Angeles
County it's going to be extended the
stay at home owners are told stay at
home orders rather they're told not to
freak out always good advice
health experts warned us yesterday that
the death toll is probably going to go
up and be higher than we thought and
that if we open up too soon that we do
it at our own peril what's your best
advice on when and how states should
start to reopen and I realize it
probably varies from state to state yeah
it really does vary at this point
because some states have seen a pretty
market decrease in case numbers over the
last month and some states are really
still seeing a rise in cases on a day to
day basis so it's like a patchwork
around the country but the four things
that really states should have in place
to to lower the risk of reopening is it
two weeks of declining cases a health
system that can really care for more
people if they get sick widespread
diagnostic testing available for anyone
who has Kovach symptoms and then a
program for rapid tracing of contacts of
cases so we can try and break the chain
of transmission we keep hearing about
testing everybody says testing is the
key I think everybody agrees that we're
not where we need to be when it comes to
testing so I want to know from you what
do we need to see and how close are we
to being what you think is smart to
reenter society I call it I think in
some places in the country where we are
getting closer there are some states
which really have brought their case
numbers down to single digits add a new
cases that makes it possible for their
public health agencies to track those
cases to find
all their contacts get them into
quarantine and try and keep this under
control and that's what countries around
the world have done that have been
successful I think the parts of the
country they're still seeing a rapid
rise in cases or daily rise or who don't
really have diagnostic testing as
extensive as they need to have or
contact tracing that's where it's going
to be more difficult and more risky for
them to reopen and and those places I
think we need to really proceed very
cautiously what's the balance do you
think doctor between hope and and
honesty for the public as we navigate
this virus and I know you're testifying
later today what is your message but I
want to hear from you the balance we
need between hope and honesty and what
will your message be today why the
honesty has to come first
we have people have to understand
situation and know what's going on I
think that's the obligation of
government and public health and
political leaders I do think that we
should have hope we a reasonable hope
doctor foul she talked about vaccine
development there are medicines under
development cases are coming down in
many parts of the country in those
states have shown us that it's possible
to bring this disease under control in
the United States other countries have
as well but we also have to be realistic
that we don't have the same situation
around the country and there are some
places where this disease could really
really and cause a much larger outbreak
so I think we have to have a balance of
both but yes there's reason for hope but
we also have to be realistic yeah your
message later today will be what my
message later today will be that we
really need to build contact tracing
around the country that's going to be
our key capacity for the next six months
to a year we have to really be able to
find cases through Diagnostics and be
able to trace their contacts that's kind
of the bread and butter Public Health
disease control strategy that's been in
place around the world we just need to
really build it up in the United States
to a place where we haven't had it
before all right and that's gonna help
us get this disease in our control all
right we're all looking for a good sign
thank you very much dr. tom ingoldsby
for talking to us this morning